Speaker 1: Let's see what else we have going on
here because we are taking calls. Let's go next to
Chiang from Taiwan. Chang, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hello? Can you.
Speaker 1: Hear me? Just.
Just. Barely, barely. Barely.
Speaker 4: I'll try. Speak up.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 4: What I wanted
to talk about today was less of a question, more
kind of just exasperation. But the Republicans and
the logic they apply to gun regulation is just
ridiculous because they never seem to apply it
to just about anything else. Imagine if the
logic that they applied to guns was applied
to abortions. You know, if people want
this, if they're determined to get this,
they're going to get it somehow. But they don't
seem to be able to see how their own logic can
apply to other situations, scenarios. And yes.
Speaker 1: The issue with that particular example
is that it can also be reversed on the left by
saying, Hey, if your argument is that by banning
abortions, you don't actually stop them, then
why do you think banning guns will work? Right,
so that one can be turned around on anybody.
Speaker 4: True. But for the left that would
be more the case that even if it's not a
100% prevention, it's still a decrease,
which is what you actually want.
Speaker 1: Well, they could say
that about abortion. They could say, yes, some
people will go and have an unsafe home abortion,
but it will be a decrease. I mean, they can
literally use the exact same phraseology.
Speaker 4: You are right in that it's
it's just very frustrating. I suppose.
Speaker 1: It's frustrating. I don't
deny that there is a double standard.
Speaker 3: I think that recently as well.
Speaker 1: Right? Right. Yeah. Well,
it's a good point, although I think that
they always have a counterpoint to it.
Speaker 4: Yeah. And unfortunately,
they don't necessarily need
that counterpoint to be consistent.
Speaker 1: No, they don't say. Well, I mean,
the right doesn't care about consistency.
Speaker 4: Unfortunately. Yeah. Thanks
for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right,
Chang, thank you very much. Very soft spoken with
with a quiet connection. Made it a little
difficult. But we did it. We really did.